[Musique]
le rugby des copines forme ovale a été
a commencé cette année pour la première
fois grâce à l'aide du conseil
départemental
et sans qui on n'aurait absolument pas
pu organiser cette action
pour démocratiser le rugby féminin qui
qui est dans le grand est par rapport au
reste de la france est un peu à la
traîne et ça a été une franche réussite
nous avons produit
quelques milliers de flyers ce que nous
avons distribué dans les collèges et les
écoles ce qui nous a apporté
des bains d'aider des jeunes filles de
collèges et de même de lycées qui sont
venus après le bouche à oreille a aussi
beaucoup travaillé on est allé en
personne même dans les et collèges et
les
lycées pour déposer des affiches et la
communication a relativement bien marché
alors le rugby n'est copine
le principe est simple à cela ce passe
au mois d'avril sur deux mercredi le
premier mercredi les jeunes filles
viennent au terrain donc à saint lui à
mulhouse à chalampé à thann tous les
clubs de rugby du haut rhin on les
attend et on les initie au rugby
évidemment il ya pas de plaquages c'est
du rugby au toucher et le deuxième
mercredi chaque l'homme vient avec ses
petites équipes qu'elles ont formés et
elles font une petite finale de rugby
touché entre elles les gagnantes sont
partis à paris voir la finale du top 14
les fier ont beau bien joué le jeu pour
la première fois cette année on a eu 74
fille sur le haut rhin ce qui est énorme
on n'aurait pas pensé en avoir autant et
elles ont vraiment joué le jeu il y en a
qui se sont découvert
une passion d'un coup qu'elle n'aurait
pas pensé et que ce soient adultes ou
louent les jeunes ont vraiment bien joué
le jeu donc sur 74 fille on a douze
filles qui sont censé signer une licence
cette année ce qui est
disons on avait pensé sur son chien 10%
donc on air on est à peu près dans la
moyenne de ce qu'on pensait et
on compte réitérer opérations en 2019 on
a appris un peu avec cette opération là
où il fallait encore un peu plus appuyé
sur sur la communication donc
en fait c'est vraiment une opération qui
est un marché super bien et qui est
vraiment refaire
[Musique]